bonjour philippe bon gars merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
vous en appelez à l'état pour qu'il
assume ses responsabilités donc mais
qu'est ce que vous demandez concrètement
alors concrètement alors les de l'état
moi effectivement t'es pas trop mal
parti
maintenant bon il paraît évident si on
ne doit pas parler de concurrence
déloyale ou de distorsion de concurrence
mais bon l'état va devoir mettre un peu
la main à la poche
parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison que dans
le passé les tailles des des compagnies
où elle encore des compagnies qui ne
sont pas forcément très productive ou
peu bénéficiaires et ne pas aider une
compagnie soit privé les mais bon qui
était complètement bénéficiaire depuis
sa création
vous faites allusion je suppose à air
france à l'état a annoncé en cette
semaine la recapitalisation d'air france
ainsi qu'une aide de 4 milliards d'euros
pour la compagnie l'état premier
actionnaire d'air france vous avez mal
accueilli cette nouvelle cette semaine
c'est ça bah après après seront d'accord
avec nous sur rochers sur ce point là
c'est que bon le gouvernement prend des
décisions et qui ont qui ont comme
conséquence un peu l'arrêt du transport
aérien
donc il paraît normal à partir de
moments aussi les six si on veut pas que
le secteur marcquois carrément il va
bien falloir que il en est tout le monde
justement vous parlez d'un secteur qui
pourraient mourir justement plus d'un an
après le début de la crise sanitaire
quelle est la situation d'air caraïbes
et de french by des licenciements des
pertes sèches du chômage partiel qu'en
est il exactement
alors pas ils apprennent de vue
économique que je suis pas le mieux
placé pour répondre les chiffres c'est
difficile de l'aide à voir on oulédi pas
tous donc mais bon effectivement on
n'est pas dans les meilleures années
d'arcari au maintenant comme l'a dit
monsieur rocher bon ben on essaiera
d'obtenir autant qu'on peut mais bon
maintenant c'est sûr que on attend le
tous les salariés attendent aussi avec
impatience et aides de l'état ce qu'ils
en ont un peu aussi hachée des projets
des projets par leurs salaires ses
dettes
l'assemblée nationale vote également
aujourd'hui la suppression de certaines
lignes aériennes intérieures dans le
cadre de la loi climat
quelles conséquences pour vous et pour
le secteur aérien au final en général
alors à court terme
fils de tron entré on voit que c'est
surtout impacté pour l'instant sur les
sur le court courrier
nous ça nous concerne pas trop pour
l'instant maintenant si on doit parler
de deux paradigmes autres de changement
de paradigme notamment écologiques bon à
un moment effectivement il va y avoir
appris qu'il sera fait on plus tranchée
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau des dalles ion
merci philippe bourgade avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué syndical snpnc air caraïbes
atlantique